Сіверщина
Комплекс Курганів. Безводівка
Стародавній археологічний комплекс, що міг слугувати пригоризонтною обсерваторією
Палац Галаганів. Сокиринці
Свіверщина вражає кількістю лісів,парків та збережених палаців
Гетьманська столиця. Батурин
Завдяки відновленню пам'яток козацької доби містечко стало одним із центрів туризму
Блакитні озера. Олешня
Колишній центр гончарства, де кар'єри перетворилися на комплекс озер з прозорою водою
Десна
Центральна артерія усієї Сіверщини та одна з найчистіших великих річок Європи
Заповідник Качанівка. Качанівка
Найбільший в Україні збережений архітектурний комплекс епохи класицизму
Оператор: Павло Пашко; Монтаж: Микола Носок; Музика: Tik Tu